each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
yes no steve harrison actually see i got
my name in in italics sorry um my name
is steve harris and i'm going to be
talking about some work we're doing at
Oxford with the NCI and increasingly
with UK government's well about semantic
frameworks about arrangements of
software services and approaches that
allow you to do well described
semantically interoperable information
systems the the kind of motivating
example for this we've already heard
about democracy from today was the the
revolutionary to mock revolutionary a
very important tamoxifen meta-analysis
that was done over a decade ago now
we're whole bunch of different clinical
studies were brought together common
variables common identity that common
pieces of data were identified analyzed
together and it was found that tamoxifen
was contributing significantly to people
survival with breast cancer Richard was
my first boss in clinical research he
brought me in from a Microsoft solutions
provider to to work on clinical trials
information systems so in 1983 this
collaborative group was formed and now
they have a consensus on 30 variables a
data model submission formats and every
five years they publish an analysis and
what this means is that we have
computable data as evidence base for
early-stage breast cancer which means
that we can be pretty sure the best way
to treat populations with the drugs and
the approaches that we have available
sad thing is is this is common in
science certainly not common in clinical
research so the cancer grid principal
investigators try to do the same thing
with sis padding in ovarian cancer
looking at some particular genes that
are implicated in cell growth and and
then got 80 studies we 4,000 patients
should get some real significant results
from this but they couldn't do
any conclusions whatsoever there wasn't
enough metadata them to take even two of
the studies and put them together with
any reliability so that they could
answer whether it was worthwhile giving
a picker with ovarian cancer this thesis
platting drugs there's also problems
with persistence of data as well Richard
doll published the statistical analysis
of the British doctors study which
proved lung cancer causation by smoking
in 1956 and but since then what's
happened well the microcircuit was
invented in 1958 and today is the 40th
anniversary of the mouse so a lot
happens these particular data sets that
have been produced I still being
gathered today and are still being used
for analysis today so the persistence of
meaning for these big population studies
across long periods of time is also very
important so we've been developing this
idea that we can put together a semantic
framework a whole bunch of tools
services and approaches that allow
people to characterize the types of data
they're recording so that data can be
reused and also to reduce the drudgery
of producing software by allowing us to
use software product line approaches as
Jeremy talked about yesterday in the in
the birds of a feather to generate
software for science for the common
experimental types that we all use we
also want architectures that reflect on
the metadata and act accordingly in
clinical research commonly we have
something called a captain Maya plot
which is a stepped plot of population
dying or succumbing to disease it
wouldn't be great if your visualization
system saw the fact that you've got a
set of death dates with no other data in
it and so actually you look like you
want to do a couple of Maya plot that
that would be a really useful Clippy to
have in your piece of software and this
is prospective and retrospective it
isn't simply about setting standards and
asking people to use them it's also how
do you go describing stuff that already
exists and released do this what you
need to do is you need to take control
of stuff you need to administer things
so I've got a laser pointer and I'm
going to use it does it work should just
point so we have these things that we
want to record terms our foundation of
understanding with the definitions that
allow us to be able to explain what our
definitions meaning and refer to a
dictionary or thesaurus from these we
still out describe the common
measurements and observations we make in
the domain now some of those will just
report some of those who want to
standard as the standardized and pre
coordinate so that we can do analysis
and then find the hour minimum data sets
our models to our information systems
are described in terms of both of these
things so that we can properly
understand what they do find the bits of
it that we want to reuse understand the
data they produce so a bit on metadata
registries I ought to get rid of those
notifier shouldn't I really metadata
registry stores common observations and
attributes and attaches value domains
and measurement protocols to concepts
from relevant ontologies and measurable
properties and it gives the value
domains meaning so that it links them
back into your ontology so that you can
uplift your data into the ontology award
when you want to do analysis or you can
use your ontology to help you work out
whether you've got the same data
relevant being declared by someone or
the data limits are relatable and they
can transform between them it provides a
structure for this and we've been using
us along with the NCI a standard called
itís a triple 179 to do this work now
this is entirely sympathetic with the
work that you 3c work that has been
described over the last couple of days
what this that standard allows you to do
is it provides a framework for the
administration of producing
interoperable data and it also provides
you with the basis for a uri
identification framework so that you can
refer to that data and its properties
which basically means that this allows
you to describe what's going on styler
so you can liberate data from the silo
onto the Semantic Web this is one of the
things we've been doing using w3c
standards the other thing it does is it
allows you to wrap up with the balls of
context so for instance density in
kilograms per meter cubed standard
temperature pressure you don't regularly
measure the temperature and pressure
around you when you do a density
measurement in chemistry or in physics
because generally speaking the variation
isn't very much but it's still part of
that context you can wrap that up into a
little ball declare it and that saves
you money because you can't always
record the entire context around your
experiments around your observation
sometimes you just have to say no this
is a little a little atom here and we're
not going to break it down any father
this standards becoming widely used dpa
in the u.s. in meteor in Australia
certainly see IDs are which many of you
will be familiar with use of standard as
do we do so what does a method actor
virtually look like this is ours so
basically it allows you to record data
elements and various parts of those data
elements so here is a a search screen
that shows pretty much the information
that a user of a data elements very
interested in so it tells them what its
name is what their other names are in
different languages it gives you a
definition so that they can decide
whether that's kind of useful to them
and and it describes what type of values
you can record it describes the value
domain so I'm focusing on this eco
performance status data relevant which
is used for characterizing the health
and well-being other patients in a
clinical study according to whether you
can't tell whether they they've got the
disease or at five whether they're dead
and when you drill into it you get a lot
more information you find out who's
controlling this you find some some
different naming languages so for
instance where we've partially
translated this into Italian and we have
not only a name but a definition in
Italian as well so somebody could come
into the metadata registry and use that
as well to help coordinate international
data share
additionally we can strap it up to the
to whatever terminology that we're
particularly interested here you can see
there's a whole bunch of uri references
that stopped at the screen in the top
right-hand corner that refer to the NCI
thesaurus and these explain and place
the meanings of the enumerations in in
our understanding of cancer and also
assert various relationships with
different data elements and this is a
place that we could put a transformation
between two different types of data
element so that we can accomplish
meta-analysis replay meta-analysis when
we want to and also we can store a
number of reference documents that
further qualify what we're doing finally
we can analyze out our metadata elements
in terms of of ontology and
terminologies and that's done in the
right way you could use that to simply
uplift into our so you have an hour
ontology to provide your domain model
you can lift up all of your data into
that area by using the subject op
subject predicate object that has been
pre curated pre analyzed here in the
metadata element but the start of the
journey doesn't need to be very hard you
don't need to understand how to use the
oncologists that there's a metadata
registry and provide a way that you
break up this process and give people a
very easy screen with four or five
pieces of information to record Who am I
who am i working for who's looking after
this registry what do I call it what's
its definition and that starts the
curation process where you record more
and more pieces of information of
meaning if this becomes works its way
into a standard then obviously more
informations added more annotation
occurs but it's simply not enough to
have this I think you need to find ways
of getting them into the hands of real
users in the places where they need them
so what we've been working on is we've
been working on add-ins in Microsoft
Office and common desktop modeling tools
because those are the places where
people need the metadata need to do the
annotation and they shouldn't have to go
to a separate website to do this work
what they should do is just
grab a bar somewhere at the side launch
a plugin go search for it and use it in
the context of their their work now I'm
just going to break out and drew a
little demo here so here's some videos
that I recorded earlier this is a play
okay so here's Microsoft Excel and what
we do you see is that they're not very
many button patterns you can use in
visual studio.net so we've got a nice
smiley face but that invokes our query
service manager plugin at the side and
what we're going to do is we're going to
search our metadata registry and we're
going to look for a data element but we
want to use so we pretty cog in in a
google style search windows lifestyle
search excuse me and and this allowed us
to go and look for the definition decide
whether Ramon sit okay so how do we use
it well that's quite simple we just grab
a range of cells press the use button
and what that does is that takes the
definition of that date of elements and
types that excel column and he puts the
name above it it puts the numeration xin
the drop down for you to use and of
course that provides with all the
benefits of validation it will stop you
from putting wrong data into the cell
and also in the background what it's
done is it's created a spreadsheet that
brings in the essential pieces of
metadata the identifiers and the getting
ahead of myself here the identifiers and
the naming and the value domain brought
that into excel as well so the whole
spreadsheet becomes semantically well
described so this piece of what lots and
lots of scientific data is recorded in
suddenly has the capability now to
properly describe what it means in a
later version of our plugins then
there's also an add data relevant button
from here as well that takes you to a
very similar screen to I showed
originally that has a very small amounts
of information that you need to record
just to get the process started okay so
let's go back you
screen
so we've been working with the NCI on
the uses of some of these plugins and
and the integration of see a dsi and cgm
deal which I'll talk about little now
particularly women there's a use case
for the National Marrow Donor Program so
what they do is they keep records of
people who would like to donate bone
marrow and this is very important
because the commune lymphoma need bone
marrow transplants and it's a difficult
process there's a lot of information
that needs to be recorded about this for
you to be able to decide whether a
person's a match quite often that match
won't be in the family so there I think
I believe about 100 forms of information
that need to be collected and what the
the marrow donor program wants to do is
it wants to take its forms and it wants
to annotate those against the candidate
standard repository cadsr so that they
can describe the types of information
they're recording better and then start
to use the tools that are in CA big to
move data around and and to do good
stuff so these hundred complex forms
they've already been entered into
Microsoft Excel into spreadsheets and
what we what we're doing is we're using
the Excel plug-in not to type columns
but to annotate and place concept
references and references to turn the
metadata elements to which this
particular piece of information on the
form related to so that they can map
together their forms to cadsr and then
finally we'll export an XML
representation of that and work with
that the spreadsheets quite complicated
this is a an example spreadsheet as you
can see there's a column there with CD
Eid I haven't a video of them this being
used in anger the next thing they were
working on is the Federation of metadata
registries because because in science
definitions of data that's collected is
a distributed process it's not a
centralized process we've been working
on the the close to the scientists
tenders the NCI been working on the
central data community control and so
what we've been doing is we've been
working on how we're going to
do this process how we're going to
exchange messages what it means that
take a data element from one metadata
registry to pass it to some other
metadata registry and how that would be
used so for instance if I'm a scientist
working wet bread lab somewhere doing
bioinformatics the data elements i
create aren't going to be particularly
rigorous they're not going to be curated
to the high standards that you would
expect for a preferred standard for the
CI big community for instance so when
see a big would take a data element that
I produce they would probably want to do
further work on it whereas I'd take
their method active elements as read
just import them into my rose tree and
just use those so here's the a kind of
an overview of the process of the going
on there's all sorts of data and
metadata sources that need to be
registered and stored in the local
cancer centers and then these are
brought together and accumulated and the
standards process is moved forward so
that you get just enough standards just
in time and not just in case as Carol
once said and we move forward to this
Prairie aware see ID SRC GMD our work
together to cope with certain types of
metadata and allow those to flow
throughout the scientific community to
them to be created in a more natural
fashion that map's the process of
knowledge discovery but we can do more
than that the thing is is now we've got
more information about our models we've
described our models in terms of terms
and metadata elements we can start
triggering from those descriptions and
we can start using those to produce
software so you can go and take a class
diagram and right click on it and say
produce me an XML schema already but if
that XML schema has identifier mappings
back to the metadata vegetarian to the
conceptual space from your ontology then
the source of annotations inside your
schema can be generated in your schema
is a fully compliant member of the
Semantic Web so this is the CDE browser
used for Korea creating forms in NC IDs
are we've got something similar but
we were quite interested in in taking
the automation further and producing a
supper production line for clinical
trials management systems so effectively
what you would do is you go to the key
or metadata databases you generate a
trial design from grabbing the data
elements described the clinical
variables you want to record then you
generate your running clinical trial
system we're moving towards using
SharePoint in this and then that XML
data can then be treated with various
tools reflect back on the schemas and
turn that into RDF so that you can use
it with all those tools that the w3c are
fostering the production of so what we
do here is we use infopath although
again we're probably going moving to
silverlight here to provide a user
interface a user environment for the
completion of the metadata about the
clinical trial and the purposes that you
want to work with and the whole process
effectively is that you make a metamodel
for your experiments you describe all of
the things that you need to know about
your experiments in inner UML class
diagram and then from that you generate
the schema from which you can provide a
user interface certain places in the
metamodel are left open so for instance
here it says that case report forms are
defined as sequences of sections or
metadata elements and it doesn't specify
what metadata elements you record so
this model could be equally be used for
cancer research it could be used for
Alzheimer's or vaccines research or it
could be used with suitable changes to
the terminology probably even for crop
yields because they're all part of
fishers randomized control trial
experiment that he devised in the 1930s
and the places for concept references as
well to provide extension points of the
common data elements you've brought in
and then you take from that as I say
already said you generate your schema
and then you can use something like
infopath to fill that in
so what we do is we incorporate the
metadata element information into the
forms in pretty much the same way as
I've shown you already with the Excel
example I have a little video of it i
think i'm going to pass on the video
because probably run out of time for i
show it to you but i can talk about this
offline but essentially you do the same
thing you have a user interface you say
at this point in this for my ones record
patient decock performance data to go
look it up in the metadata registry yeah
I've got quite a few slides to come back
so maybe come back to that I really
ought to turn off that notifier so data
shaving services let me do that now
before before I get really embarrassed
shall I somewhere there should be some
Google notifiers I can't find them
doesn't matter let's take let's live
dangerously shall we where's my full
screen view the jury please don't the
world I sorry I've slightly got
distracted by that page display keep
going down keep going down right full
screen mode great excellent the thing is
is now that we've got a recipe for a
data sharing service so I've got this
model of what it is to be a phase 3
clinical trial but I could equally have
a model of what it is to be a
long-running epidemiology study or a
retrospective observer spective cohort
or or any two other type of experiment
I'm interested in I just follow the same
recipe I take somebody's standard of hat
what they think we should be doing when
we record information about this
clinical research I derive a model from
that and I ornament that model with
terms and concepts and metadata elements
from appropriate ontology and that
allows me firstly to pre curate my
experiments to describe what i'm doing
but also if it's post curation if i'm
taking something that exists already
then i'm making an entry that describes
annotates the work that's done and can
describe the data model of the data that
i want to share
so I can catalog experiments with this I
can have a whole I could have a trial
register for instance which describes
all the current learning clinical trials
or I could go to a large
well-established reefs medical research
organization and I can say well this is
how we're going to curate all of the
large population data sets that you have
available and this is how people are
going to navigate around and draw
commonality between them you could ask a
question of i'm interested in survival
information with lung cancer and this
type of network will a network of
concepts and metadata elements and
models will allow you to answer that
question quite clearly bring in a whole
bunch of datasets and then try to decide
whether they're useful and whether you
want to contact the people who own it to
do data sharing so we've got a number of
examples of generation the stuff that
I've been working on uses a number of
open source tools and w3c tools so i
work in xquery quite regularly Charlie
and Andrew who sit beside me do this
kind of work in SharePoint but i'm not
on presenting stuff that i can talk
about rather their sharepoint which i
don't quite understand effectively what
you do is you take the metadata registry
and you use that to ornament your class
diagram from your class diagram you can
generate an XML schema and then from
there onwards you're into a generation
path part of the generation path talks
about how you take the form in your
application framework and present to the
user stuff the data in that you want
them to edit with the form part of it is
also about recovering extra information
from the model that you've been doing
the annotation schema doesn't have all
the information that you might want to
show on the floor so you've got to find
ways to recover that ultimately you
could go back and look in the metadata
registry for things like the question
that you want your phone to ask so your
data element might be called patient eco
performance status but your question
might be please assess the patient's
performance according to this scale and
it will go back to the metadata registry
if you've got that information bring
that into your form and
allow you to use that in your
application and it all works very simply
with xslt is a little fragment of a
stylesheet transform that looks for an X
forms input called change description
and then says we'll just replace this
for a text area for FML box basically
and you can get this kind of
transformation relatively
straightforward you can also ask
questions that there are a number of
annotations you can put in your metadata
registry that could key default
transformations in your generation
framework and what we're doing is we're
using this with a group who study
vaccines particularly childhood vaccines
in Oxford University the CCP TM and we
are going to be using this to generate
an information system for this a cwy
trial that looks at a couple of
different meningitis vaccines so that
you could get immunized for meningitis
if you go into a place where meningitis
is prevalence beliefs sub-saharan Africa
is one such place so the process
basically goes as you go through the
forms and you register metadata elements
for each of the items on the coast
report forms and then you get a
registered schemer generating traffic
I'll hopefully show you and then from
that you can offer the the form just by
bringing in the different schema
elements and simple types how you want
to use it and then once you've got
schemer generate the xform and and
deploy it to your attic application
framework with with aunt in this case
this is the sort of work that we're
going to be doing with sharepoint and
silverlight we we've just been funded by
microsoft to take this work forward in
early phase cancer clinical trials as
Jeremy talked about in the verge of the
feather yesterday and all of these tools
will be recast and made much more
powerful in this environment the great
thing about share points is that the
actual amounts of extra work you need to
do to get this working is much much less
than if you were deploying against jboss
or or in this case exists assignment
going to show just that then mean that
yes okay I take my life it's my hands
here and somewhere down here and I
should have a virtual machine and if it
comes back to me then maybe we can show
some generation right before I do that
what I will do is I go to my metadata
registry and so I control- here I should
be able to get slightly smaller result
my login would it come back to the
center you can just ask the other side
of the Kree screen here I've just gone
to the maintenance section at the bottom
here I've got something called schemer
so what's happened here is this semester
day to register that has all the data
elements for three of the forms in the
ACW white royal and I can just simply
click on the scheme of functionality and
what that will do is that will go and
calculate what these metadata elements
look like as an XML schema with the
sorrel annotations that refer directly
back to the the metadata registry so
that it's all well characterized so I've
got a schemer let's open it up with a
little bit of luck oxygen will kick into
action in a second and we can have a
look at the schema and see what it looks
like so value domains in this world get
transformed into simple types and data
elements become XML elements of type
simple type it's as straightforward as
that if so here's the schema I just
whoops no that's putting it away still
haven't got used to that bit of you can
tell I've spent most of my life in
Windows so here you can see there we are
so how could a simple type here it's a
restriction on a string with a
numeration of yes or no so it's simple
boolean style feel and here I've got a
URI that points back to my metadata
registry and identifies this particular
data element with
the particular schema elements with this
part of the identifier for the value
domain okay and similarly so those the
value domains later down in the schema
I've got all the simple elements okay
and what they do is they associate a
name and a tight together and again they
have the identifies here in the sort of
legends white space of the metadata
element itself rather than the value
domain so this is a w3c schemer with
semantic annotations generated
automatically from a system by people
who don't need to understand what
schemer looks like to get this to work
and simply I can just start entering the
model for my form at the bottom of this
particular schema so if i go to my
virtual machine the one-loop that's not
the one
there we are why God some I from machine
I should have command window here so
firstly here's my exist database just
show got nothing looking up my sleeves
I'll refresh I don't have any other
collection script and why my unscripted
building nation will take every all
those pieces of information it will
generate grab all you may have before
and we do the work for us and provide
ourselves with a complete application
and when it gets to the end we're going
to have a look at what that application
looks like so here we are restoring some
schemers now to the xml database and
write the very bottom it says my build
successful which is really good i can go
and have a look for it inside my
inside my database yes here we got a CW
why you don't have a look what's inside
it auntie as you can see I've got
various bits and pieces here I've got
some webpages here I've got some xforms
in here and then I can go see my web
browser I would have done all of this in
Windows but parallels trashed my boot
camp so a little challenged in that
respect and I can go to a cwy trials
management system and I've got a working
system now that I could I got forms that
will enter and produce data come back to
me please
I think all right yes so let's log in
because I shouldn't be able to enter any
data if I don't log in and I can go and
create a new registration form and that
will load up my ex form it will show it
in the browser and as you can see I've
got all of the different bits and pieces
and sign like Mike a support for my
required fields are outlined in red it's
brought in all it knows that state field
for instance so it will put the date
value in and then once I've entered it
again this is just in the style sheet
itself there's no programming to get
that kind of work to occur my drop-down
lists have all got the different values
in there and I can just submit this to
the foot the form to the server and
record the form as part of my trial
management system okay so real software
last couple of slides now so one of the
things that we're excited about here is
is some of the opportunities for very
large amounts of data sets being
gathered this was something I noticed in
analyst at the beginning of the year it
may look just like a couple of shoe
boxes to you but what this is is this is
a PCR amplifier analyzer that
essentially has a bill of materials cost
of a thousand dollars many as you can
see runs with an apple macintosh here as
it happens but any old laptop you can
plug into it run the software on there
and you can imagine sticking a couple of
these in the back of a land rover and
taking them out to the sedan for
instance and monitoring disease epidemic
outbreaks and these pieces of infirmity
sees you can use this to work out
whether somebody who has the disease
relatively quickly but it's very
difficult you've got to be able to move
information around very fast for
instance in SARS it took just five days
in 2003 to sequence the coronavirus and
with the tools are becoming available
we're going to have to move lots
information around dataset definitions
instrument parameters new terminologies
ontology need to be generated
automatically and what the framework
I've described starts to allow you to
think of how you'd build those systems
without knowing a single thing about the
disease target that has appeared because
you can define a model for the
instrumental parameters for that pcr
device to record the new virus that you
just brought back sequence and analyzed
there's some couple of nights tools here
that talk about automatic ontology
generation and use this is something
called Terminator terminus org if you're
interested in it and what it does is it
takes a sample of text that you've
entered into it and it runs it against
the oboe foundry and it annotates and
asks you whether these terms are the
ones that you mean and you can go down
and you can say yes I didn't mean a
particular term no I meant that one can
i search for another and then
effectively annotate your chunk of text
against the ontology is and then save
that as XML or as IDF to reuse later on
in a similar way to that previous
talking some other things that have been
talked about there's a lot of work going
on at the moment about text mining to
generate at least fractions of ontology
so this is a great paper by chris
brewster SL robert stevens and simon job
where what they did is they mined a
whole text corpus for animal behavior
and gave david shots and who works at
the University of Oxford fragments of an
animal behavior ontology which he did or
the arrangement foreign created in in
record time quite a sophisticated quite
a detail animal behavior ontology with a
great deal of coverage they haven't got
to the point where they could generate
the whole ontology from the text I think
that probably is something that that
will be difficult if not impossible
we're just plain text but the point
where you've got a whole bunch of
information you can gather fraction
fragments of ontology and then arrange
them into something that's very useful
very quickly I think that's a really
interesting development so ultimately in
conclusion
we and various people are working on a
range of tools that you can imagine
providing this semantic framework allow
scientists users to manage their
metadata and communicated to other
people and then to standardize on those
things that are necessary to obtain data
sharing and interoperability in their
data community and they provide this
framework for the persistence and
characterization of meaning within the
desktop applications they are working on
so that it may be used with all of these
great w3c tools that we've heard people
talk about and that we use quite
regularly at Oxford but I can test that
these tools work best when they're
embedded in people's real working
environments which is essential that
it's as easy as possible to use these
annotation tools because if they're not
that easy then people will just not do
the annotation finally just a few
acknowledgments of all the people who
have been working on and providing
valuable advice for our group in Oxford
on this thank you very much
okay you'll cover specific experience
you seen as nomads the ontology yes we
it works we played around with sno-med
and we've we've hooked it up three
features the player to see how the thing
looked and yes it works quite happily
sno-med you can get as an hour ontology
you can downplay the owl ontology into a
Scots representation and then it just
loads into the metadata registry
directly we've done that with mesh we're
currently working on the NCR thesaurus
because one of the use cases that we
want is somebody modeling on an airplane
where they haven't got any internet
connection or where they're behind a
firewall perhaps in a pharmaceutical
company who don't want to expose what
kind of work they're doing but one to
ensure that they're interoperable with
the standards they're out there so they
need to be able to bring their own
copies of the whatever resources they're
using in-house into their own tools and
then we use it so yes it will work quite
happily with snowing and one more
question over here
hi hi I'm Jay how quickly are the
standards changing and how hard is it to
keep the data that's been encoded in
some sort of standard up to date with
the current standards well that question
kind of comes in two parts the first
part is the metadata registry allows you
to describe what is there how it was at
the point of data capture and that's an
important part of the function the
second part is it provides quite
flexible ways of taking that definition
at the time and relating it to the
current context to our current
understanding of things so the way it's
linked into the oncologist for instance
talks about how we see that in our model
of the world today so yes it for that
well I wouldn't pretend that some of the
issues that surround that moving forward
over decades and the repurposing and
reuse of data outside the original
context our problems that are solved but
at least you have the start and you have
the ability to do these things in the
placeholders where you put this bit need
pieces of information and once you've
got data like this then you're you can
just load the whole stuff spill it out
into RDF and start playing around to
your heart's content and query the
metadata later simultaneously and see
what transformations that you can
produce so thank you very much and thank
you to all our speakers and we
appreciate it thank you